242 OF THOSE GAMES
MARTIN, CARRIES ON, MOVING IT
IN.
A DROP PASS, BACK NOW ANDUCK OUD
A TWO-ON-O FOR NEW YORK TO START
THIS GAME, PAGEAU TOOTHING
BUT THEIR SCHEDULE, IT HAS JUST
BEEN CRAZY WITH THE NEW
BUILDING, 13 ROAD GAMES TO STARS
TO ON CONSECUTIVE
NIGHTS AND WERE NOT TO SLOW
THIS DOWN AND THAT PULOCOC THE S
NOW, TIPPING THAT O THE ISLANDER
DEFENSE AND JUULSEN, THIS TIME.
YOU CAN SEE IT., DEFLECTED OFF F
GREENE, JUULSEN, HOOKED, BY
THATCHER DEMKO.
>> John G.: OH, BOY, A NICE
LITTLE TOUCH PASS THERE.
AND THE
GOING UP, OUT OF PLAY AND THAT
.
>> John S.: THE PUCK, SENT
AHEAD, HÖGLANDER IS
THE PUCK NOW COMING BACK,
EKMAN-LARSSON WITH THE
INCLUDING TED GREEN AND SAVE.
HUNT, TO THE LINE, TO THE
MIDDLE, TEEING IT UP AND MYERS
THERE WITH A SHOT.
TH THE
CORNER.
>> John G.: A GOOD PLAY BY HUNT
COMING IN, DEFENSIVELY.
>> John S.: AND PE
THERE'S SEVEN MINUTES LEFT IN
THE SECOND IS
BEAUVILLIER, INSTEAD OF GOINGEC!
[ Horn ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
[ Horn ]
[ Applause THERE.
A LONG WRISTER THAT TIME BY LUKE
SCHENN.
PELECH.
PEARSON.
GREENE.
INTERACCEPTS.
COULD NOT GET I ON THAT
CENTERING PASS AND ISLANDERS AND
IT IS BARZAL, DUMPING THAT PUCK
IN.OR
ILYA SOROKIN, ,
THAT MOVE, AT GLOVES OFF.
>> John G.: AND AFTER TWO
PERIODS SCHENN HAD SIX DUMPING T
DOWN INTO THE VANCOUVER ZONE.
AND
SCORING CHANCES AND THEN SECOND.
BAILEY.
CHECKED BY
COROLLA